[Music]
[Music]
the use of digest for me are really
important because it causes you towards
an image how do you make music out of
die Jetix how do you remove the
separation between sound design and
music and turn them into one and that
was the ultimate goal here is kind of
taking diegetic sounds with the rhythmic
form and saying let's combine this and
make something beautiful I'm Dan Mays
film director from Cape Town we've just
wrapped up the TV commercial and short
form for Tasker fly 42
[Music]
coming from a short-form background
looking at this you know I was like it's
going to be so difficult to tell a story
in 60 seconds rather let's tell a
feeling you know we're kind of doing on
the ground research we came across this
company called flag 42 which was ran by
a guy called khaki gun his ideas to
bring people together through using
music it's such a brilliant idea to give
Kenya one voice and essentially that was
kind of what we were going for is to say
you know what would happen if we went to
Kenya to film the 42 tribes of Kenya
kind of find significant sounds from
each tribe and create one anthemic
soundtrack through using an original
track by slim Annie and kind of
recreating it in a contemporary way just
finding the balance between how far can
you stylize and how far you can keep
things completely organic and authentic
and I think that we were able to really
pull up that balance beautifully which
for me is a success
in a shoot like this I think it's about
having your trust in the production team
eventually everything just fell into
place and production just did such a
brilliant job and kind of making sure
that everything that we wanted to get we
ended up getting and more what tusk is
doing is saying you know we are bringing
people together as Kenyans and through
using ordinary Kenyans kind of creating
something extraordinary which is the
soundtrack it's bigger than one person
it's something that every single person
can enjoy because it unifies Kenya and
it kind of brings in every single
element from the super traditional rich
and heritage to the more contemporary
young fresh kind of market
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh